نيران الجحيم التي يجب أن تكون واحدة من
أبرد الأماكن على وجه الأرض
في القطب الشمالي الروسي يحرق رجال الإطفاء الذين
التقينا بهم بالقرب من مدينة ياكوتسك في أقصى شرق البلاد والتي
تكافح لإبقاء ألسنة
اللهب بعيدة ، لدينا الكثير من الأراضي التي
يصعب الوصول إليها ، لذلك نحتاج إلى آلات ثقيلة عن طريق
في الوقت الذي نصل فيه إلى هناك ، يمكن أن ينتشروا
بعيدًا جدًا هذا العام ، لقد انتشروا في مناطق
بعيدة للغاية ، حيث اشتعلت النيران في
جميع أنحاء شرق روسيا تقريبًا مقارنة
بهذه المنطقة في الولايات المتحدة
ازدادت حرائق الغابات في سيبيريا سوءًا مع
ارتفاع درجة حرارة كوكبنا في نفس الوقت
الذي تساهم فيه غازات الدفيئة التي تنبعث في الهواء
في زيادة الاحتباس الحراري
بمقدار 50 ميغا طنًا من ثاني أكسيد الكربون في
الغلاف الجوي بسبب الحرائق في مناطق القطب الشمالي
في شهر يونيو وحده ، يقول العلماء إنه
ترك الأرض المحروقة وراءه.  لذا هنا
ترى أحد الأسباب التي تجعل هذه
الحرائق خطيرة للغاية وتنتشر
بسرعة كبيرة ، هناك الكثير من
الشجيرات الميتة والأشجار الميتة هنا في هذه
المنطقة التي لا تشتعل فيها النيران
بسرعة كبيرة فحسب ، بل تخزن أيضًا أطنانًا من
الكربون الذي يتم إطلاقه الآن في
تعرضت مدن الغلاف الجوي مثل ياكوتسك
لدخان كثيف لعدة أشهر
بينما تذوب مؤسستها حرفيًا مع ارتفاع درجة
حرارة الكوكب ، وهذا
ما تبدو عليه هذه المنطقة تحت الأرض
، وهي مبنية على التربة الصقيعية أصبحت الآن
أضعف مع ارتفاع درجات الحرارة هذا الصيف
في التسعينيات.
يقول معهد ياكوتسك للتربة الصقيعية إن العالم
بحاجة إلى خفض الانبعاثات بسرعة حيث
يتزايد عمق الذوبان  يقول إن
نقطة اللاعودة هنا تقريبًا ، فنحن
في نقطة حرجة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالتربة
الصقيعية وهذا ما يبدو عليه عندما
يتم الوصول إلى نقطة اللاعودة ،
تظهر المجاري العملاقة مثل هذه في
جميع أنحاء سيبيريا وتنمو  الصوت
الذي تسمعه هو الجليد والأرض المتجمدة
يكسران تغير المناخ أثناء
العمل ، يسمي الروس هذا المكان
بوابة الجحيم لأنه يبدو تقريبًا أن
الأرض تنهار والعالم السفلي يبرز
إلى النور وهناك مخاوف في
هذه المنطقة من أن
التعرية السريعة مثل  قد يؤدي ذلك إلى تدمير
مدن بأكملها قريبًا جدًا ، كما أن ذوبان التربة الصقيعية
يطلق أيضًا كميات هائلة من الكربون المخزن
في الجليد الذائب مما يزيد من تأجيج
النيران الجهنمية التي تشق طريقها الآن
عبر القطب الشمالي في روسيا وتؤثر على
مناخنا في الوطن فريد كما في سي إن إن
ياكوتسك روسيا